[Music]
hi i'm zooming with kent vlieger
south dakota's soil health specialist
just to talk about a series of videos
that
kent shot in may 2020 can't we have
eight videos we'd like for folks to see
and
i wondered if you could give us a little
bit of context of
why you were in the field shooting these
videos
sure so like you mentioned buzz the
2019 really the whole calendar year was
very wet in in south dakota
most places had twice their annual
precipitation
a lot of prevent plant and we went into
winter freeze up really
still quite wet a lot of rivers were
still in flood stage and
going into winter so this spring there
was
quite a bit of anxiety on whether we
were going to
kind of have the same disaster we did
last year since we had so much moisture
already in the soil profile and so what
we were looking to do
is show some of these fields
and conditions and then we were really
looking to
show producers that have been practicing
soil health practices
for uh some for a couple decades and
some a little shorter term
and just to see how they were handling
um
all that excess moisture from the
previous year and if they were having
any success with planting or what some
of the challenges
that they were facing all right thanks
kent that gives us an idea of what to
expect hey i hope these videos are going
to be useful to
producers especially as they
start thinking about 2021.